For every WandaVision fan theory that turned
out to be right, there were many more times
WandaVision's story zigged when people thought
it would zag.
Many of us confidently identified early on
that Agnes was actually Agatha Harkness, who
would go on to be the show's big bad by season's
end, but that proved to be the exception and
not the rule.
When Evan Peters turned up claiming to be
Wanda's dead brother Pietro Maximoff, for
example, people immediately leapt to the conclusion
that this was proof of a full-on X-Men-MCU
crossover.
After all, Aaron Taylor-Johnson played Pietro
in the MCU's Age of Ultron, whereas Peters
was a part of the former Fox X-Men lineup.
With the next Doctor Strange movie entitled
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness,
there was every reason to suspect more of
Fox's mutants were on the way.
Another major question arose thanks to a cheeky
comment Paul Bettany made in an interview
with Esquire indicating the show had one more
major cameo coming before season's end.
Bettany said,
"It's an actor I've longed to work with all
my life, and we have some amazing scenes together
and the chemistry between us is, I think,
extraordinary and it was just fireworks on
set."
Who could it be?
Sir Ian McKellen as Magneto?
Maybe Mark Hamill?
The guesses were all over the place.
In the end, both of these big questions were
answered in ways that punked fans a little.
Peters was playing a nobody actor named Ralph
Bohner controlled by Agatha,
“Bohner?”
“Heh, Boner…”
and the actor Bettany had great chemistry
with was… himself as White Vision.
Naturally, fans had pretty strong reactions
to the twin deceptions, and now Elizabeth
Olsen herself has stepped in to respond.
In an interview with Variety, Olsen spoke
about fan theories, picking on both the true
identity of Pietro Maximoff and Bettany's
promise of a final "cameo."
She said,
"I knew that there are theories that had to
do with people wanting more surprises in cameos,
but I'm not really that aware of what these
fan theories were, so I'm kind of learning
about it as we go.
Paul said something about this crazy cameo
when he was really just talking about doing
a scene with himself, and I know Paul thought
that was a really funny joke, and I thought
it was funny.
But I was like, I think people are actually
going to suspect that there is more to come."
“I’m starting to believe that everything is meaningless.”
Spoiler: fans most certainly did think there
was more to come.
As for Evan Peters playing Pietro, Olsen pointed
out that the possibility of a Fox-Disney crossover
wasn't even on her radar yet.
She said,
"I didn't know about the multiverse when we
were filming this.
So I wouldn't assume that that's what was
happening.
I thought it was just a clever way to have
a Pietro.
I didn't understand the larger plan of the
multiverse until I started working on 'Multiverse,'
or whatever our movie's called — the Doctor
Strange sequel!"
It's worth noting that this is the second
occasion where a multiverse has been hinted
at but not delivered.
“There are multiple realities Peter.
This is Earth dimension 616 and I’m from
Earth 833.”
“I’m sorry you’re saying there’s a
multiverse?”
The first time took place in Spider-Man: Far
From Home when Mysterio tricked people into
thinking he was from an alternate universe,
when he's actually just a very elaborate illusionist
and thief.
Paul Bettany also weighed in on the topic
during an appearance on Good Morning America.
He asked of the hosts,
"You know when you think something's gonna
be funny and then you say it and you actually
panic about it?
Which is what I did because fans started guessing
who it might be, and they were guessing, like,
Benedict Cumberbatch or Patrick Stewart.
I was thinking 'God that's a good idea,' and
they're gonna be so disappointed when they
find out it's me."
“Is it really you?”
While some fans may be annoyed at the subterfuge,
White Vision is an important part of the ongoing
Wanda and Vision love story.
After all, with Westview's version of Vision
gone, the only hope Wanda currently has for
another chance with her husband is through
the White Vision - who was last seen flying
away to parts unknown.
As for the Pietro fake-out, this isn't the
first time Marvel pulled something like this.
In Iron Man 3, Sir Ben Kingsley was supposedly
cast to play The Mandarin, but turned out,
just like with Peters, to be an actor named
Trevor Slattery.
Of course, Evan Peters could still play Pietro
in the MCU someday — and Sir Patrick Stewart
or Sir Ian McKellen could turn up as mutants
eventually, too!
This could all be just a long con and the
multiverse is still upon us.
Somehow.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.